americans are facing our heart-wrenching
choices thanksgiving
here's a question to see family and
friends and potentially put them at risk
or
stay home aaa was expecting up to 50
million travelers this holiday but that
was before new guidance from the cdc
and their advice to you is stay where
you are the reason is an alarming uptick
in cases including
more than 172 000 new ones yesterday
more than 2100 people were reported dead
in that 24-hour period
that's the most in a single day since
early may
chris vancleave is at reagan national
airport outside washington chris good
morning
well good morning you can take a look
behind me here you can see what holiday
busy looks like
in washington the tsa says this airport
has only recovered about 25 percent of
its passenger traffic from
pre-pandemic levels but other airports
across the country in chicago dallas
houston denver several in florida
are at 60 to 70 percent of where they
were before the pandemic
so people are traveling but whether you
were a go or a no-go this year
for many that decision was not easy
despite the covet warnings americans are
on the move
as long as you know everybody wearing
masks everything's clean it's nice
i don't mind it more than four million
have already passed through airport
checkpoints
and tsa is expecting today will be one
of its busiest since march
sometimes you're in a crunch and you got
to do what you got to do you're going to
see those barriers if you go to any
airport they're going to be very similar
tsa administrator david pakoski showed
us some of the latest covet protections
in place including plexiglas
officers in ppe and new scanners do you
think people should be traveling
i think passengers need to make a
judgment my job in tsa and my officer's
job is to make sure that if you do
choose to travel
we provide you a safe and secure
experience as we possibly can
just last week the cdc followed mayors
and governors and urging people not to
travel for thanksgiving
those arriving in los angeles starting
this morning will be required to fill
out a health form
asking them to quarantine for two weeks
or risk a 500 dollar fine
and in new york city police will be
looking to enforce quarantine rules
pia duriere is driving to see her
parents in connecticut
it was a really difficult decision to
make
the cds i respect what the cdc
guidelines are
and it's made me think real long and
hard about it
both are in their 80s and recovering
from summer health scares
i wanted to go see them because you see
all these stories about people who
who wish they had seen their family
members before they got sick
but philadelphia healthcare worker
samantha halpern told her family to stay
in st
louis just two hours before their flight
as cases climbed
they decided this year would be a zoom's
giving i'd rather not have them come for
this thanksgiving than risk
not ever spending any future holidays
with them from here on out
now aaa expects up to 50 million people
will go somewhere for thanksgiving this
year the cdc is urging
folks if they do do that to wear a mask
when they're around people they don't
live with particularly indoors
or dr john lapook suggested breaking up
the thanksgiving eating from the
thanksgiving socializing meaning when
the masks are off
separate come together to socialize with
masks on ideally outdoors or in
well-ventilated spaces
tony it's going to be a personal
decision for every family but those cdc
guidelines are clear chris thank you
very much